[Music]
people need to understand that all of
North America is indigenous land it is
native land people tend to forget that
there was a vibrant native culture
living in all parts of North America and
food is really the piece that's going to
help us move forward into a brighter
future my name is Sean Sherman and I am
a chef
I own the company the sous-chef so this
is going to be two pieces per plate for
these our mission is revitalizing Native
American foods and re-identifying North
American cuisine we've tried really hard
to maintain authenticity by removing all
of the colonial ingredients like dairy
wheat flour processed sugar beef pork
chicken and we're just using a lot of
wild game a lot of the native
agricultural heirloom bridles a lot of
the wild foods around us and are really
making those plates that tastes like a
region most of these ingredients are
very familiar to people but the usage of
a lot of the wild plants really talked
about a place in the community
[Music]
we prioritize purchasing from the
indigenous vendors first because we
really want to open up a lot of
opportunity for indigenous people
growing out firearms are collecting
things from the wild or raising animals
so for the big dinner we're actually
cooking this bison down with a bunch of
fresh cedar and some bergamot we will
purchase from anybody raising these
indigenous pieces because it is such an
important part of the landscape in the
history you know you want it as we
travel around the country we like to
make dinners and foods that really
represent those areas what's great about
being able to do these dinners
especially in non-indigenous communities
is just to bring awareness this kind of
food that we're eating today like you're
gonna feel really good when you leave
here you're not gonna feel heavy and
weighted down you're gonna feel
energized and just happy because you're
knowing where this food is coming from
we feel like anybody across North
America will benefit from the
understanding of the indigenous food
systems around you and it's all going to
help us move forward
[Music]
white corn is one of our relatives we
feel that she is alive she wants to do
the job that she told our Creator she
would do is to feed our people to
nourish them the work that we do if we
didn't have this way we would lose
everything
[Music]
for a few thousand years Potawatomi
people have been incredible farmers and
have grown a lots and lots of varieties
of crops the seed library is a place
where we take crops which are
disappearing rare and endangered
Potawatomi vegetables and we grow them
out and we restore them and put them
back in the hands of native farmers
[Music]
George Martin carries the Potawatomi
tradition of making Dom Nabu or corn
soup in our seed library we have 76
unique varieties of corn each one has
its own cultural identity its own unique
flavor after a while when we stir it
you'll see how tough it gets the stirrup
our corn is a lot different than other
corns which are out there if we didn't
have the seed library these traditional
food might be gone forever
within our seed library 80% of the
varieties which we take care of our rare
or nearly extinct some of the varieties
we care for here we're the only place in
the world which has them this one's
gonna be a nice one four years ago when
we first got another signal gar white
flowered corn we only had a half the
canning jar a very small amount of seed
we've grown it every year since and now
we have enough that we may have a
hundred bushels fall that's enough that
next year we could plant six or seven
acres of just this corn that's a huge
increase
it is important that we - I thought we
were sent down here for to take care of
Mother Earth and all her creations here
and that corner realizes that we're back
using it again
and we're going to use it in the feast
makes the corn feel good that they're
being used by our people again it's done
it's ready to eat the market for culture
art is huge unfortunately almost all the
native art that you find either online
or in stores features fake Native
American art when I walk into a store
and I see cultural art from my community
that's counterfeit it feels like a
family photo on a product in a store
it feels that personal to me and I
wanted to do something about it
[Music]
my name is lui Gong I'm a nuke sac
tribal member and I'm the founder of
eighth generation which is based at Pike
Place Market in Seattle when I walk
through the mall almost every store has
native art on products in it and not one
of those products is connected to a
native artists to me that represents a
huge problem and eight generation tries
to address that problem by creating
actual opportunities for cultural
artists to develop products I'm a
self-taught artist and about ten years
ago I started doing art by customizing a
pair of shoes and I had developed a
really strong organic following from
doing that work
we know that people want to buy native
art so that eventually became the
foundation of eighth-generation
[Music]
we have about 15 different business
relationships with makers within two
miles of Pike Place Market when you buy
products featuring art done by Native
people and produced by Native owned
companies you're strengthening the
cultural art and the communities whose
artwork you like we're the first Native
owned company to offer wool blankets
this is important because the aesthetic
of wool blankets has largely been native
when people think of wool blankets they
think of Native art I think people are
used to seeing native people in one of
three categories
you know we're typically a charity
project or a symbol of history or a
symbol of the natural environment we're
planting a seed about who native people
really are and so when they walk in the
door the message that gets conveyed is
that we're alive and we're thriving and
that contradicts what people
think about native people eagle feathers
give us that strength encourage to go on
[Music]
they've been in our ceremonies for
centuries and to be able to have these
feathers in our time of prayer and our
time of need is really important to us
we're at the National Eagle repository
last year we received right at 2,700
Eagles that were found dead or died for
one reason or another and we provide
boosts feathers from Eagles to Native
Americans for their religious and
cultural purposes they are protected by
various laws such as the bald and golden
eagle Protection Act so people can't
just go picking them up but this this
way it allows Native Americans a lawful
way to obtain and possess Eagles the
birds that we get have died from various
causes
they often collide with something it
causes them to break a wing and of
course results in death but usually
those injuries are pretty minor to the
feathers so we we could still use most
of the feathers so we're checking what
needs to be replaced there or what
feathers need to be added in in an
effort to try to give him the equivalent
of one whole bird
the role of the National repository it's
very important it helps us to keep going
with our lives that we know it
[Music]
from the be anytime from creation point
out people occupied this area that's how
deeply rooted our connection is to the
village it's a very sacred and we will
be moving my name is fawn sharp I'm
president and CEO of the corral Indian
Nation Co notes an Indian tribe located
in western Washington we're surrounded
by water a good part of our citizenry
and population fishes if not
commercially we fish for subsistence so
the problem is our village is vulnerable
to flooding and extreme weather events
due to climate change to the point where
I've had to declare two states of
emergency in the last two years and our
entire village could sink into the sand
and disappear it's very hard to
reconcile those two things to know that
this is a very sacred resource but it's
also a resource that could wipe out our
entire village
the permanent fix ultimately is going to
be removing the entire community to
higher ground we'll be moving about a
thousand people and the cost for that
move is going to be about 65 million
dollars and we hope to have a good part
of this done within the next 10 years
today if you are to drive in the upper
village all you would see is an access
road it's still very wilderness like
trees grass I see a place where it's
very safe it's built on rock it's not
vulnerable to either sinking or being
taken out by a tsunami it seems like our
younger generation is really embracing
the concept they're going to be the the
ones that would be occupying and
residing in the upper village
you